[Music]
when I was 13 I thought I had discovered
the most incredible diet the more I ate
the more weight I lost but this diet
came with some really unusual side
effects I was constantly tired I was
always thirsty eventually my mom took me
to see the doctor and this is where we
got the bad news I'm sorry you have to
go to the hospital immediately to begin
treatment you have diabetes my first day
at Children's Hospital they taught me
how to inject myself with insulin but
frankly I didn't mind I was actually a
bit of a science nerd and I liked
getting to play doctor the second day
they taught me how to count the number
of carbohydrates in my food
but again I'm good at math this is going
to be totally manageable but on the
third day reality sonken they explained
how difficult this disease is to manage
how expensive my supplies would be and
that there's no cure I remember sitting
in my hospital bed feeling shattered how
was I going to manage this house my
family going to afford this what did I
do to deserve this I quickly became
ashamed of my condition because I felt
so different and I hid it best I could
into my 20s but if it did come up for
some reason I made sure to clarify that
I had the genetic type of diabetes not
bad type you get for being fat and lazy
but this was wrong and I was simply
passing on my shame to other undeserving
individuals shame is the diabetes
complication we need to talk about and
today I'm going to walk you through what
diabetes is why it's so difficult to
manage and why we need to change the
conversation one in 11 Americans have
some form of diabetes but what exactly
is this condition
at its core diabetes means that your
body has difficulty turning
carbohydrates aka sugar into energy but
there's a couple ways in which this
system can go wrong with type 1 diabetes
your body suddenly unexpectedly stops
producing insulin the hormone that turns
sugar into energy a type 1 diabetic like
myself has to inject insulin every day
in order to survive
now with type 2 diabetes your body still
produces insulin but your cells have
trouble using it treatment can involve
pills to increase your insulin
sensitivity or potentially doing extra
insulin shots with both conditions the
level of sugar in your blood fluctuates
much more wildly than it would normally
when it's too high you face fatigue and
more importantly art risk of long-term
organ and nerve damage but if it goes
too low it's as if your body is running
out of fuel and your brain can slowly
shut down now both of these conditions
have genetic drivers but actually type 2
diabetes the type that 90% of people
living with diabetes have has an even
stronger genetic component totally
negating what I said before
now the conception that we all have
though is that while type 1 diabetes
strikes suddenly and you can't do
anything about it
type 2 can get worse with poor diet and
exercise you notice anything missing
from my explanation that's right that
giant ice cream sundae that you ate this
weekend will not give you diabetes now
if you ate that ice cream sundae every
meal every day for a couple months okay
you might be at higher risk of diabetes
but even then that wouldn't determine it
the point I want to get across here is
that a diet high in sugar can be a
contributing factor to diabetes but it
is not the cause of diabetes so now you
have a better idea of what diabetes is
why is it so hard to manage can't you
just take this pill or take insulin and
salt the problem the truth is that this
can is that the system is extremely
complex
according to diatribe a diabetes on
profit there are 22 factors that
impact the level of sugar in your blood
food and insulin are the obvious ones
but did you know that stress and even
altitude can have an impact let me give
you an example when I was taking the
GMAT exam I had to pick my poison I knew
that the stress was going to cause my
blood sugar levels to slowly climb and
fatigue me but if I took insulin to
bring this down I was at risk of going
too low and my brain shutting down on
the mid exams the truth is is that your
body is like NASA using supercomputers
and satellites to land a rocket on the
moon everyday to get your blood sugar
levels just right now someone with
diabetes still has to land this rocket
on the moon everyday but you're doing
the math by hand and you're measuring
the variables with a telescope as you
can imagine things go wrong a lot and
when I was recently on a hike with my
friends I suddenly realized that my
blood sugar was at a dangerous low level
and I felt embarrassed when I had to ask
them to stop and wait a second while I
desperately tried to scarf down some
candy to get my blood sugar levels to
come back up so my brain could start
functioning at its soul level and while
this happened because my body failed me
and because of many factors out of my
control I couldn't help but feel
personally responsible and this brings
me to my last and most important point
why we need to change the conversation
according to diatribe 50% of individuals
living with type 1 type 2 diabetes and
over 70% of individuals living with type
1 diabetes believe that there's stigma
associated with their disease that's
right the majority of the 1 in 11 people
living with IBS feel ashamed we feel
like we're a burden not only to
ourselves but to our friends to our
family we feel embarrassed when someone
questions our ability to play sports or
to have cake on our birthday as I
mentioned I hid my disease into my 20s
this means that I would do my insulin
late or sometimes not do it at all I
would eat whatever my friend
our eating because I didn't want to feel
different but the truth is that these
actions were incredibly self-destructive
so now you may be asking what changed
how am i able to get up on this stage in
front of you and talk about diabetes to
be an advocate for the cause to want to
go into the diabetes industry after I
leave the GSB for that I have to thank
my former mentor Tobias we lo Tobias had
two kids that were type one that had
type 1 diabetes and he was my Ally he
would come over to my cubicle at work
and talk to me about the latest diabetes
technology if someone said something
misinformed
he would make sure and speak up Tobias
helped pull me out from under the weight
of my shame and empowered me to take
ownership of my disease and for that I'm
incredibly grateful shame is the
diabetes complication we need to talk
about and now you're armed with a
knowledge of what it is why it's so
difficult to manage and why we must
change the conversation but what exactly
can you do first don't use diabetes as
the punchline to your joke
please don't hashtag diabetes when you
splurge on a giant Slurpee at 7-eleven
it belittles a really complex and
difficult condition secondly if you're
hosting a dinner party and someone there
has diabetes don't assume what we need
us we all treat our condition a little
differently and I for one would love to
add some of that amazingly delicious
cheesecake that you make now on that
point if I already have a bite of that
delicious cheesecake in my mouth I
promise you I can be eating it it's not
going to kill me you don't need to
double check but I appreciate it and
finally if you see something or hear
something misinformed
say something it can be really difficult
for us to stand up for ourselves in
front of a large group you
now now why diabetes is so complex and
the factors that make it so difficult to
manage let's work together to remove
shame from the equation
[Applause]
[Music]